hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge I'm Kamali Melbourne live
at 9pm here in the heart of Westminster
on a day of utter chaos and British
politics with Liz truss's Premiership in
real Danger
Braverman resigns as Home Secretary
after breaching the ministerial code she
says she has serious concerns about the
direction of the government and its
commitment to honoring key Manifesto
pledges
Grant chaps is the new Home Secretary
just weeks after a now cornered PM
sacked him from his previous role as
transport secretary say there was no
room at the end
the eyes to the right 230 the nose to
the left 326.
dozens of conservatives including the PM
herself abstained in a crunch vote in
the Commons on fracking a vote Tory
whips had early declared to be a vote of
confidence in the government
[Music]
but just after the vote there were
rumors the government Chief whip Wendy
Morton and her Deputy had resigned
amidst allegations of intimidation in
the voting lobbies
I have been very clear that
[Applause]
that I am sorry and that I have made
mistakes
well earlier it was a bruising prime
minister's questions for this truss
where she committed to the pension's
triple lock contradicting her
Chancellor's comments yesterday and what
appears to be another Utah
a book is being written about the prime
minister's time in office
apparently it's going to be out by
Christmas is that the release date or
the title
a secure starmer taunted the Prime
Minister as the labor leader once again
says there must now be a general
election
all that as the PM canceled the visit
and suspended a senior political advisor
on a day that's left Downing Street in a
turmoil will bring you the takes from
all sides in the next 60 minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
or good evening if the last few days and
weeks have seemed chaotic today took
things to a new level it's perhaps an
understatement to say that Liz trusses
political future is in Peril this
evening her home secretary swella
Bradman resigned over a security breach
but dropped a political bombshell by
declaring she had serious concerns over
the direction of the government dozens
of conservative MPS including the Prime
Minister herself abstained in a vote
over fracking even after Tory whip said
the vote was a matter of confidence that
was followed by extraordinary
allegations of intimidation and even
physical bullying in the voting lobbies
then when the result of the vote came in
there were rumors that the chief Whip
and her Deputy had resigned now at
lunchtime the PM had another bruising
session at Prime Minister's questions
just a second after which another
conservative MP openly said she should
resign
all right well a little later in the
program I'll speak live to the shadow
Home Secretary Yvette Cooper but let's
first bring in identity political uh
correspondent John Craig who is with us
here in the studio John I mean I think
we're running out of superlatives to
describe what's going on aren't we well
it's chaotic and it's still chaotic
because there's no still no official
confirmation that Wendy Morton the chief
whip has resigned just to take you
through the events of the day which
you've already summarized the events in
the Commons tonight followed a debate on
fracking on a labor motion calling on
the government to introduce a ban on
fracking and uh also proposing that to
bring in a bill to do that on the 29th
of uh of November now Tori said that
that was Labor trying to take control of
the order paper this morning this letter
was sent to conservative MPS by Craig
Whitaker the deputy chief whip it says
it's a hundred percent hard three-line
whip this is not emotion on fracking
this is a confidence Motion in the
government and uh we cannot allow this
now
as the debate Drew to a close with after
some conservative MPS had threatened to
Rebel despite that a Graham Stewart the
climate Minister winding up the debate
for the government said no it's not a
confidence vote at all and as you've
said 40 MPS conservative MPS did not
vote and the list is incredible it's not
it's not quite fair to say they all have
stained because there were some had
reasons why for example the defense
secretary Ben Wallace is talking Ukraine
in Washington with the Americans but the
list has got some interesting ones the
government Minister Stuart Andrew
Tracy Crouch ex Minister was thought to
be a rebel wanted to Rebel David Davis
Nadine Doris Ian Duncan Smith Aleister
Jack the Scotland secretary Boris
Johnson said to be on holiday in the
Caribbean Jillian Keegan Minister kwazi
quateng sacked last week as Chancellor
Theresa May former prime minister Wendy
Morton the chief whip who it's claimed
is now resigned um pretty Patel former
Home Secretary Angela Richardson she was
planning to be a rebel alok Sharma the
cop Minister Chris Skidmore he was
wanting to Rebel Mark Spencer a former
Chief Whip and Elizabeth truss the Prime
Minister what's going on there and Ben
Wallace who I mentioned now it is
thought it's been claimed that the Prime
Minister decided under pressure from MPS
to scrap the all this tough talk about a
confidence vote and allow MPS
essentially a free vote without telling
the chief whip who let's not forget
Wendy Morton one of her closest friends
and allies and and so Wendy Morton
resigned on the spot still no
confirmation and that's before we get on
to talk about swella Braven which I'm
sure you're going to ask me about I am I
am but before we move on to swella
Braven let's talk about those
allegations of intimidation and bullying
I mean the chief whip are there to
enforce discipline in the party but this
is probably taking it a little far what
happened was there was a hold up during
the devote the vote the deputy speaker
Dame Eleanor Lang was in the chair and
as quite often happens in contentious
votes uh she said there's a hold up in
the lobby go and find out what's going
on now it turns out there were some what
MPS have described as some pretty unruly
scenes allegations of bullying Chris
Bryant the labor MP raised a point of
order talking about bullying and
intimidation he then came on Sky News
and mentioned that a conservative MP
Alex Stafford a 90 a 2019 red Waller
from Rother Valley in South Yorkshire
had been bullied and intimidated and the
speaker is said to have asked for an
investigation carried out by the deputy
speaker who was actually in the chair at
the time all very unseemly we don't know
if the chief whip still imposed but the
government does look as though it's
falling apart you mentioned Chris Brown
to raise the point of order I mean we've
got his picture right there that he
tweeted up we can bring that up again
and we can see pick out a few of the key
people in that picture I believe you can
probably see the back of the head of
Jacob who's not the business secretary
Teresa coffee is in that picture as well
yes when he uh Mr uh Bryant gave an
interview to Sky News as did Jacob Reese
MOG spoke to our colleague Sam Coates in
the central Lobby
um Mr Brian didn't exactly point the
finger of bullying and intimidation at
uh Mr Rhys Mogul to raise coffee but you
can see it's pretty crowded nothing
unusual in the uh in the members Lobby
being crowded during a vote it would be
um but you can't actually see it just
looks very crowded there and no doubt
there was a bit of pushing and jostling
it's claimed that this MP Alex Stafford
was sort of marched through well we've
heard stories about that before but it
all does sound as they'd all got a bit
ugly in there and uh perhaps clearly
there was a backlash amongst
conservative MPS against this tough
letter they all got this morning telling
him it was a matter of confidence they'd
lose the whip if they voted against the
government but we had a complete climb
down yeah as well as what we heard from
Chris Brown when he spoke to some
coaches several MPS have also tweeted
about what they saw happening I think we
can bring some of those tweets up as
well now John I mean talk to us how
these votes work can they have timed out
could that have been the reason why
um the prime minister is trust and able
to get into the into the lobby in time
it is a mystery why the Prime Minister
could invoke because I was here in the
studio with Dermot mernahan earlier and
we were watching the voting going on
from the camera at the bottom end of
these uh chamber the one the other end
from the speaker and we saw Liz truss in
the chamber and a lot of the people on
that list I've just read out I mean for
example I've seen lots of those MPS
around Parliament today Stuart Andrew
the minister uh David Davis I saw him at
the 1922 committee earlier Ian Duncan
Smith
um clearly Ben Wallace is on important
government business Theresa May I
suspect she just didn't fancy voting uh
she she tends to just stay away when
there's something she's not too keen on
rather sit on her hands like some MPS do
in the chamber to say look at me I'm
abstaining
um but um
clearly the government is losing control
discipline is collapsing well exactly
let's go to that story the Euros then it
just feels like a long time ago now but
the home secretary's gone we've got a
new one in place now this was just
before five o'clock this afternoon now
uh the new Chancellor Jeremy Hunt was
addressing uh conservative MPS at the
1922 committee at five o'clock just
before that we got the bombshell news
that the home secretary's got now in her
resignation letter she says she sent an
official document from her personal
email to a trusted parliamentary
colleague we now know that that is her
political soul mate her Ally on the
right wing of the party Sir John Hayes
veteran Tory MP and ex-minister it was
with the X she said with the aim of
garnering support for government policy
she says she says it was uh the advance
draft of a written ministerial statement
about my migration a lot of the stuff
was in the public domain she said and
then
comes the the sexy stuff if you like the
chunky stuff about really putting the
boot into the Prime Minister the
business of government relies upon
people accepting responsibility for
their mistakes now to be fair Theresa
May did admit mistakes at the beginning
of prime minister's questions pretending
we haven't made mistakes carrying on as
if everyone uh can't see that we've made
them and hoping things will magically
come right is not serious politics I've
made a mistake I accept responsibility I
resign then it gets worse it's obvious
to everyone we're going through a
tumultuous time I have concerns about
the direction of this government not
only have we broken key pledges that
were promised to our voters but I've had
serious concerns about this government's
commitment to honoring Manifesto
commitments
such as reducing overall migration
numbers stopping illegal migration
particularly the dangerous Small Boat
Crossings for which of course she was
responsible for the last few weeks so a
pretty a pretty uh terse and stroppy and
disgruntled ex-home secretary there
Grant shafts turned up at the home
office he's got a huge job on his hands
he looked delighted uh clearly surprised
to get the call today but Grant chaps
only a few weeks ago was criticizing
um uh Liz truss at Fringe meetings and
in interviews at the Party Conference
what a turnaround we've now got uh um
we've now got Jeremy Hunt who
incidentally went down very well with
conservative MPS at the 22 tonight and
Grant Sharps not from Liz toss's wing of
the party not her political soul mates
or Allies at all in two of the top jobs
in government yeah it's quite a
turnaround it's 11 time in politics John
really appreciate that we'll speak to
you again later in the program all right
let's uh get the view now from the
conservative party I'm pleased to say we
can bring in uh Danny Krueger who is the
conservative MP for devisers Danny
Krueger good evening to you thank you
very much for being with us so I wonder
if you can just clear up what happened
in in the lobbyist this evening we've
heard reports that there was bullying
intimidation
what took place
and very
very dismayed at those reports I don't
really believe them I I mean I I noticed
that your sources are opposition MPS
obviously you know the atmosphere is
febrile uh as journalists say you know
things are very bad for the government
and no doubt there are harsh words being
exchanged but I'm afraid that is
politics I'm afraid I don't believe that
there is ever serious you know
intimidation of bullying along the lines
that have been described certainly no
matters okay so you're suggesting that
those MPS who who made those statements
in the Commons chamber and then on
social media and then on news channels
we're lying
well they're exaggerating I'm sure I
mean they're they're twisting the knife
in in what is extremely painful moment
for the party but as I say I didn't see
it anyway uh I find it very difficult to
believe that that went on to the degree
that was that is being reported but
listen the fact is our party's in a
total mess the government is in is in a
very bad way they've been a series of
mismanagements uh I'm afraid to say
among the in the whipping operation
which is really difficult job to do so
dealing with hundreds of colleagues who
are very worried and you know and we're
a divided party at the moment so but the
fact is that there have been some
significant mistakes I think over the
last two days we've seen that
particularly in the way folks have been
whipped so I'm afraid uh you know while
I made supportive of the government I
think that I don't think we've got any
real excuses to make things are not
being managed well in Parliament at the
moment yeah there's low The Wider policy
and the economic strategy that would be
this year we'll come on to some of that
later don't agree if we can but I mean
at this stage do you know if the Q flip
is still in it's still in post
no afraid I'm getting my news as as you
are uh no I I I heard the rumors some
hours ago that she resigned so I I don't
know but if I met after the less that we
saw this morning Mr Kruger saying that
this was a three-line whip it's a vote
of confidence in the government and then
when the vote takes place so the
government win handily
there are rumors that she's resigned
yes I'm afraid I can't comment on on
those rumors I do have sympathy with the
whip so even though I think that
mistakes have been made because you know
they're trying to manage a very very
difficult situation and while as I've
said we've got to face facts and
attribute responsibility where it
belongs in terms of decisions made by
ministers we are in the context of an
enormous change in our economic and
social model that has been building for
decades we can certainly point fingers
at the way the government managed its
mini budget the other day but really
what happens it pushed things over the
edge that were falling anyway you know
our model of our economic model has been
built on 30 years of cheap uh Capital
cheap credit cheap labor on a
centralized public sector and on an over
leveraged uh private economy that
doesn't distribute wealth properly so we
have got to change our economic model
and all this I mean I appreciate it's
important very important about who's in
which government job but frankly moving
around ministers is so secondary to the
fundamental challenges we have as a
country which is to get our economic and
social model right and recognize the
mistakes which well predate the
conservatives being about obviously
predict there's trust but predate David
Cameron too and go back to the 1990s so
we've got to seize this moment live up
to our responsibilities as politicians
and take some really really difficult
decisions which are going to be painful
and we've got to be honest about what
that entails for the coming months and
years well do they include the Prime
Minister resigning
well as I say I I I appreciate the
importance of the question I I I don't
want a little that but really this is
not about the personalities of who's
holding which office
if if you don't mind I mean I've read
what you you put on on Twitter about
this uh new social Covenant and it it's
really Secreto it's a Manifesto for a
way that you want the government to run
the country and it's completely
different to the way that this current
prime minister is running the country
it's very you put it on 20 minutes ago
an hour or so ago rights when the
government was in this turmoil this
latest round of terminal so that's not
very supportive is it of of your prime
minister it would seem as if you don't
want her in office well I'm not I'm
afraid of going to get into the business
of commenting on individual ministers
and whether I think they should be in
their roles or not we'll just let the
drama of politics play out on that front
what I want to happen is and I believe
it is trust could do this as well as
anybody is to reorient our economic
model and our social policy towards the
real really important foundations of
growth which are about stronger families
strong Community is restoring our
national Integrity through border
control through getting our rights
framework properly founded again and
investing in the foundations of growth
that means public service reform it
means Devolution to communities it means
supporting the economies of households
rather than just individualized welfare
payments and taxes there's a totally
different way of thinking about our
economy more manufacturing focus on on
regional growth not just on boosting the
finance sector and on ultimately cutting
taxes by reducing the demand on a state
that is driven by social breakdown those
are the priorities that I think any
conservative government should be
adopting and I am confident that Liz and
her colleagues could do this but it does
the direction that we need to go in yeah
and you've made uh your position very
clear on that Mr Kruger as I say you've
done the Tweet the Tweet thread so
everyone can read it there on your
social media but you backswell a
relevant early on for the leadership and
obviously she resigned as Home Secretary
just earlier with quite excoriating
letter that many have seen as perhaps
positioning herself for another tilted
leadership will you support that
well let's see there's there's No
Vacancy I mean I support Australia
because I I believe in in her and her
vision and but I I regret her departure
from government and and you know I pay
tribute to her for her because I didn't
have anything uh supported to say for
the current prime minister in her
resignation letter
well there's obviously some uh some
chagrah there I I guess there's you know
she's extremely pretty sad to be going
but as as now is about venture
she's allowed as I am to politely if she
has done so just said
indicate her disagreement we know we are
a political party we're all hand
together but we also have disagreements
and sometimes those have to be expressed
publicly and so I think it's absolutely
within Savannah's rights to indicate in
that courteous way that she has some of
her anxieties about the direction of
travel
Danny Krueger do appreciate your time
this evening thanks for being with us
all right you're watching the take live
from here in Westminster and up next
we'll have more on the future of the
Prime Minister
foreign
[Music]
let's get more now on the reaction to
what's been another chaotic day I'm
joined by the conservative MP for
ruislip and northward and Pinner David
Simmons David Simmons good evening to
you love you good evening in the studio
with us um so look
um uh Danny Krueger said he didn't see
anything happening in London I want to
get your take on it because you were
there as well
um what took place because there are
some serious allegations of intimidation
physical manhandling of people so we've
been promised an investigation like
Danny I was present I've been present on
many occasions in Parliament where
there's arguments and disputes going on
in the lobby but that investigation
clear needs to take place our colleague
who allegedly was manhandled says that
wasn't the case but there are those who
say that something happened clearly that
needs to be investigated and we'll see
but emotions were running very high in
Parliament tonight and all that drama is
a bit of a distraction from the need to
get on with the proper job of government
yeah but the emotions need to run so
high did this need to be set as a
three-line whip earlier in the day and
then change during the debate I mean it
seems like a game the government have
set themselves up for a full so
opposition day debates when the labor
party in this case get to decide what's
going to be debated have been flash
points before and I think we need to
recognize that I'm not sure it was as
well handled as it could have been but
the important thing is that we made what
in my view was the right decision in the
current energy crisis that we would give
local communities the opportunity if
they were happy for it and they'd been
through a proper consultation and they
thought it was the right thing to do to
allow fracking in their area we know
that things like natural gas a key
resource is not just for energy they're
used for things like agricultural
fertilizer oil is used for manufacturing
not just for burning in cars so it is
important following all the events that
have happened since the last Manifesto
was drafted that the government is able
to react to what's happening try and
protect people's household budgets and
family finances but how much of that do
you think is going to be lost Mr Simmons
by the fact that the Prime Minister
herself wasn't able to vote because of
something that was going on in in the
lobby well I don't know the reasons why
all the people who weren't able to vote
didn't vote and they were quite a lot
and we know for example there were a lot
of colleagues who were away abroad they
were on things like trading significant
people who were here some big names who
were here who didn't vote Theresa May
the Prime Minister herself quasiqua take
many many people who were here in lobby
chose not to vote and no matter what we
do what may have gone on yeah so I say I
think you managed to get through you
need to put that question to those
individuals I I was able to vote without
any difficulty I saw most of my
colleagues were able to do so but those
people they may have had permission to
be absent they may have been trying to
say something to the government we don't
know the answer that I'd rather take of
you once I've got proper facts what do
you know about what's happened with
Wendy Morton the chief whip we the
reports that she's resigned uh I don't
know I'm hoping perhaps Sky News will
enlighten me on that subject but it's
certainly been in the media
um we'll find out in due course we'll
try and Enlighten you I can't give you a
little bit of breaking news in the past
10 minutes Lord Frost has said that he
wants uh Liz trust to go of course a
little trust form a brexit minister and
uh has now said that it's in the
interest of the party
for her to go your reaction to that
first of all but as a relatively new MP
like Danny Krueger you heard from
earlier on my big focus is on getting
the policies of the government right I
don't have a strong view about the
personalities that are in charge of that
in my view this dress has made a good
start she's made some good appointments
I think the decision to appoint Jeremy
Hunter's Chancellor whatever the
circumstances is something that's gone
down well both in the markets but most
importantly and the difference that's
making so what will happen with people's
budgets so we need to make sure that we
carry on in the right direction now this
dress will be listening to what's been
said if we get a government that
stabilizes with the right people in
those right roles then I'm confident
that policies which are the things that
make a big difference to families and
households in this country can be got
right and how do you make sure those
people are in the right roles I mean it
seems at the moment that once there is a
lot of noise made maybe the market is
getting upset that Liz truss is making
decisions on the hoof because it does
seem as if some of the decisions have
been made quite quickly let's go to the
sweller Brotherman decision
there are some reports that perhaps you
didn't need to resign it was a technical
breach that's how she describes it in
her own letter
yes I mean I've read the letter that she
wrote and clearly she accepted that
she'd breached the rules and on the
basis of that because it was something
which she should have known that she
shouldn't have done that it was right
for her to go but clearly you know
across the conservative party across
Parliament there's a lot of talent it
was very striking when Jeremy Hunt made
his budget statement for example that
there was agreement cross-party that
these were the appropriate measures to
stabilize the economy and to bring that
sense of financial relief to households
in this country that is the right
direction for us to be going in and I
don't have a strong view about which
individual it needs to be that's behind
those policies we need to make sure that
we are pragmatic conservatives and that
we are taking the economy taking the
country in the right direction and
forgive me for thinking it might be a
little mischievous but it would seem as
if it was in her interests to resign in
that way and also as we've seen in the
letter
um laid out quite clearly that she made
a mistake she resigned I mean she's
speaking very clearly there to the Prime
Minister isn't she the Prime Minister
said Magna apology again at the dispatch
box today that she made but she what she
was very clear about was that she'd made
a mistake she'd made heiris object in
good faith and those were things about
policy things that may have worked out
exactly in the interests of the voters
of the people in the way that they were
intended to and it became clear from the
reaction of the markets from what was
going on globally that that was not
going to be the case and she changed
Direction and I think that was right now
clearly that is different from an issue
of rule breaking which is what led to
the home secretary's resignation
technical bridge and you said you're a
new MP so you must be concerned about
what this could all of this turmoil that
we've had for the past few weeks because
how long has it been
um that the party has been facing is
doing to your party because at the
moment you're way behind laboring the
polls and there are real concerns that
you could be wiped out if there was an
election very soon well clearly people
will be looking at the opinion polls and
asking what it means for them the bottom
line is the party has a 70 seat majority
in Parliament it's around two years to
go until a general election is required
and we know that a lot of the things
that are going on that are really
impacting on households in this country
are part of global context which will
take some time to feed through so as we
look at for example the reduction in gas
prices that's happening on the wholesale
markets that will bring some relief to
people as we get through the winter and
that's an example of how we might see a
medium-term Improvement in the way
people are I accept that I'm talking
about you as a conservative you joined
sorry became a member of parliament in
2019 it's very new so are you happy with
the way that you see the conservative
party right now at this moment so I
think the conservative party is
absolutely the best party to lead and to
run the country and to run the
government but it's my view that we need
some policy changes of direction we
begin to see see some of those things
happening in the last few weeks so the
new chance for statement clearly is
something which both has been well
received in the markets but also
beginning to feed through into how
household budgets small businesses in
this country are affected by that that
for me is the right direction of travel
the conservative party has been
pro-european anti-european it's been
pro-free markets more about central
control in its history it's about making
the right decisions in the circumstances
that we face in the interests of the
British people I'd appreciate time David
Simmons thank you so much for being with
us this evening okay all right you are
watching uh the take Live From The Heart
of Westminster and then the next minutes
we'll take a closer look at pmqs
[Music]
and I'll come back this is the take it
really has been an extraordinary day in
Westminster and one that leaves Liz
truss's political survival hanging in
the balance the Home Secretary has
resigned dozens of conservatives
including the Prime Minister herself
abstained in what was supposed to be a
three-line whip vote on fracking and
there have been allegations of physical
intimidation well let's bring in Lord
barwell Gavin barwell who is Daniel
Chief of Staff to former prime minister
Theresa mayor law Bible always good to
speak with you thanks for being with us
so look these allegations of bullying in
the lobbies you were there during some
of those late night votes over brexit
you ever seen anything like this
no no I mean I think the scenes tonight
reflect very badly on Parliament and on
the government
uh I was a government whip for a number
of years you know that that kind of
behavior is completely counterproductive
and I think that the general scenes
tonight speak of a government that is in
its last days I mean in his last days is
one way of putting it what happened then
do you think what broke down here
because as we saw from this morning
there was that letter sent out that this
was a three-line whip a motion of
confidence then during the debate as uh
John Craig was telling us earlier that
changed and it almost became a free vote
and then we saw a bunch of people your
old boss not voting at all how did that
come about
well I wasn't in the division Lobby so I
can't tell you what happened
uh in the space there but clearly the
government's position over what the
whipping Arrangements were changed at
the last minute and that is inevitably
going to lead to confusion
but you have to ask the question about
why those arrangements are changing at
the last minute and what that says about
the current state of the government and
its ability to provide the leadership
that the country needs well precisely
and what does it say
well I I I think that the the position
is pretty clear that the prime
minister's time time as prime minister
is coming to an end her Authority is
seeping away you've got ministers
resigning today or being sacked it's not
entirely clear
you've got ministers right now that are
unable to tell us whether the chief whip
is still in her job or not so the
conservative party has a duty to the
country to provide Effective Government
and right now the one bright spot is the
chancellor of the exchequer I think
Jeremy Hunt since he came into office at
the end of last week has significantly
stabilized the position in terms of the
economy but the rest of what's going on
is frankly a complete shambles and it's
an embarrassment to the country it's an
embarrassment to the conservative party
and the sooner it comes to an end the
better
okay well that's what's going to be my
next question then Lord by well I mean
how much longer has this thing got to
run
well that's that's in the hands of
conservative peace but I mean they need
to reflect on whether at the moment the
party is providing the leadership that
the country needs and whether these
scenes reflect either well on the
country as a whole or on the
conservative party only they can resolve
this situation
but they need to do so and they need to
do so quickly I mean there are two huge
issues here of course I mean the
conservative party is one thing and you
will be uh very tied to the future of
that party but as you mentioned the
country as well that is seeing a
government that's in complete chaos do
you think there are some conservative
MPS or perhaps lacking the courage to do
what needs to be done
I I think I think a lot of conservative
MPS are feel exactly as you've described
about the government at the moment what
they're trying to do is to see if they
can find a way to resolve this issue
quickly rather than subjecting the
country to another three months of the
leadership
but I think that the frustration that
you voice I don't know if you've you've
seen the interview with Charles Walker
this evening who's a highly respected
long-serving back bench MP
and I think the emotion with which he
spoke this evening speaks volumes for
the current state of affairs within the
party you're quite right to say that the
fundamental question here is about what
is the national interest
and that is what should guide the
conservative party and it's what should
guide its MPS and the national interest
is not being served
no it's not it's not being served but so
Lord what do you make of some of these
rumors of the way that this does get
resolved with you know uh a dual ticket
of Rishi sooner company modern or
bringing back Boris I mean all of those
potential ways through this
um have their own pitfalls don't they
so I think bringing back Boris Johnson
is not the answer you know on policy
grounds there was lots that the Johnson
government was doing that I would agree
with but I think his behavior as prime
minister fell well below the standards
that we all have a right to expect so I
don't think that's the answer to the
problem that the party in the country
who finds itself in at the moment
I think if it's possible for some of the
most senior and talented people within
the party to agree on a kind of joint
ticket to try and resolve this situation
so that we can have a rapid transfer of
power and we don't subject the country
to several months of the leadership
election which it really can't afford in
the current situation that we find
ourselves then I think that would be a
good way forward if it can't do that
there is going to be huge pressure on
the public clearly for a general
election so I'm sure a lot of those
discussions are going on right now but
it needs to be resolved as I said
quickly because the current situation is
not tenable but I'll put this to you
like this though I mean that might be
neat and tidy for the party but the
public at large are definitely not going
to like that to have another
um leader installed another prime
minister installed today the calls for a
general election will grow even louder
you might even hear it from some people
within the party
so look I'm obviously lots of people are
going to call for an election I mean I
would I would sort of gently observe to
you that during my lifetime more people
have become Prime Minister through an
internal transfer of power within a
party than through winning an election
so it's not like this doesn't ever
happen
the the hand I think or the the case of
the party if you like will be
strengthened if the new government that
replaces this one returns closer to the
manifesto on which conservative MPS were
elected it's worth reflecting that
tonight's events
are about a vote on fracking when the
conservative Manifesto in 2019 said very
clearly that there would um that the
fracking wouldn't go ahead so actually
the trust government tonight was trying
to whip conservative MPS to vote for
something that was contrary to the
manifesto on which they were all elected
so but I understand your point entirely
lots of people are hugely frustrated
with the current situation are going to
argue there should be an election if
conservative MPS don't want that they
need to demonstrate quickly to your
viewers that they're capable of changing
this situation of delivering the
stability and competence that people
have a right to expect from their
government and as I said at the moment
there is one bright spark which is that
the change of Chancellor Jeremy Hunt has
made some difficult painful decisions
that have stabilized the situation in
terms of the financial markets but the
chaos that you've seen today with
resignations and what's going on in
Parliament this evening as I said does
not speak well at all
okay Lord by well uh always good to have
your thoughts on this thanks very much
for now all right let's bring back in
our Deputy political correspondent John
Craig so John where do you want to pick
this up should you pick up with what
Gavin barwell was saying that that his
ideal version will be some kind of dream
ticket between uh Rishi sooner company
modern or two others who are capable
enough to run this party I think what
I'd probably say to Gary and ball is
Dream On on the dream ticket because
this is the whole thing the um the uh
the party the MPS cannot agree on a
candidate this idea of a a coronation or
a couple of senior figures coming
together that there are so many people
and their supporters who want the top
job Rishi sunak and his supporters Penny
Morton and her supporters even now
Jeremy hundy suddenly back in the
running in the leadership Stakes as well
and then there are those who want Ben
Wallace even though he says he doesn't
want the job but let me bring you two
pieces of if not
strictly speaking breaking news
significant developments in the last few
minutes number one number ten have told
us Liz trust did vote hold on I know I
know a little piece of paper that's a
Commons list
um that clearly there was a problem in
the voting Lobby in terms of people's
cards on the electronic thingy or
whatever one MP told me he James
dudridge contacted Sky News say I voted
even though I'm on that list now
secondly and even more significant
perhaps Steve Baker the brexitier
Northern Ireland Minister has told Sky
News that neither Wendy Morton the chief
whip nor Craig Whittaker than her Deputy
have quit he's told Sky News this is Mr
Baker I saw the deputy chief whip as he
was leaving the commons and he said
neither he nor the chief whip had
resigned he was most emphatic so I'm not
sure we're going to do a breaking news
uh Chief whip has not resigned by saying
I'm not resigning I haven't resigned
it's an interesting way to say goodbye
to someone well
um she um I mean clearly
clearly what's happened is or from all
the accounts well not perhaps not
clearly unclearly what's happened is
that we know that um this letter went
out first thing this morning to Tori MP
saying this is a confidence motion and
it's a three-line Whip and anybody who
doesn't vote for it will lose the whip
then there was this spectacular regular
U-turn late on not long before the vote
at seven o'clock when number 10 said no
it's not a confidence motion Graham
Stewart the minister announced it in the
house it's claimed at that point Wendy
Morton felt undermined and quit now
we're being told she hasn't or or she's
been persuaded by the PM not to quit
we'll find out more John thank you very
much for that are you getting all those
texts all right you are watching the
take live from Westminster and up next
I'll speak to the shadow Home Secretary
Yvette Cooper
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the take
let's bring in now the shadow Home
Secretary event Cooper very Cooper good
evening to you thanks for being with us
first let's see if we can try and get
some more information to what happened
in lobby today rumors of intimidation
bullying some aggressive behavior you
were there did you see anything
it's certainly clear that there were
some angry discussions taking place
wasn't clear what but what was there's
no doubt about is it was total chaos and
you had the chief whip being sacked and
then being not sacked or being resigned
and then not signed at the same time as
we've also had the Home Secretary being
sacked the chancellor sacked just five
days ago this is total chaos and I think
shows that the conservative government
is really just coming apart at the seams
and it is not fair on people right
across the country who are really
worried about what's happening you know
to their mortgages what's worried about
what's happening in their communities
and seeing this kind of chaos right at
the heart of government I mean you've
been in Parliament you've been in
government for you were in government
for a long time and you've been in
Parliament a long time um what do you
put it down to and don't be parties I
don't just say it's just because it's
the same old stories what'd you put it
down to that we're seeing this level of
chaos right now in this government well
I have never seen anything like this you
know I've been an MP for 25 years I have
never seen anything like this it is just
totally chaotic I think they're not
focusing on people across the country
who you know need a government that
takes seriously the state of the economy
that takes seriously our national
security these big issues of state that
are just somehow being ignored because
there is so much fighting so much chaos
and it just feels like there are no
grown-ups in the room and so I do think
this is a party issue because ultimately
we've had 12 years of the conservatives
just unraveling we're seeing the
consequences of their own failures and
their own decisions and now fighting
over it in this totally chaotic and
incompetent way but people across the
country working people are paying the
price from this crisis because they're
seeing mortgages go up they're worrying
about crime and anti-social behavior in
the local communities and now worrying
about fracking as well because the
government's just trying to force that
through as well it's really chaotic
really unfair on people I mean to be
fair to them bringing in Jeremy Hunt has
stabilized the market somewhat hasn't it
so that was a good decision something
that needed to be done to try and make
sure that there was a little bit of
stability well they've had reversed all
of the decisions that caused you know
huge problems but the damage is done
that's the problem because of that mini
budget because of the chaos around it
because they ignored the office of
budget responsibility our serious
Economic Institutions mortgages are
still up and people are still paying
more people are really worried about
paying hundreds and hundreds of pounds
more on their mortgages every month as a
result of this Carnage right at the
heart of government and that's why I
think in the end it's not enough to
change a Chancellor it's not enough to
change your home secretary or your Chief
whip ultimately we need a change in
government it is time for a general
election I mean inflation was ticking up
as you will know so they will say that
um by bringing in uh Jeremy Hunt that
has stabilize the Microsoft which let's
come on to your Shadow brief then so now
you're facing Grant chaps I mean you
obviously know him from all the time in
Parliament that you've spent um what how
do you expect them to be different from
other Home secretaries that you face you
face a few yeah I think the problem
again is this is about shuffling the
deck chairs but the ship is still going
down and that's why I think it doesn't
really matter who the Home Secretary is
if you still have this chaos and
confusion at the heart of government we
know that ground shapes even just a
couple of days ago was talking about how
he did not think that Liz Tross could
survive we know there's been you know
all sorts of those difficulties and I
just don't think this is about setting
for a positive plan for the country
we've still got the real problems with
serious violence with anti-social
Behavior you've got people just not
being charged for crimes the number of
crimes being solved has plummeted and
that's as a result of the 12 years of
conservative policies all of which Grant
shops has been part of so there's no
real Sun that anything is likely to
change on those serious issues around
crime policing and the things we need to
keep people safe just what talking event
Cooper I've been told by my producer
that's them
the conservative party have confirmed
that Wendy Moore and chief Whip and
deputy chief with Craig Whitaker do
remain in post tonight so those rumors
that they had resigned uh were just
rumors you know seriously I mean you
know they as we heard initially they
were sacked and then they were unsacked
that they'd resigned then we heard that
there was a resignation letter that was
written was it sent was it not sent and
then the Prime Minister was in talking
to I mean when you've got that kind of
mess it means those basic things you
need governments to be able to get
legislation through Parliament you need
therefore a chief whip in place that's
working sensibly with the Prime Minister
you need to know that National Security
decisions are being taken well so you've
got to have a proper relationship
between the Prime Minister and the Home
Secretary and you need markets to be
stable you need a proper economic plan
to put the country right so you need a
relationship between the chancellor and
the Prime Minister all of that seems to
have fallen apart this trust seems to be
in office but not in power not making
any of the key decisions other than this
chaotic stuff about about sacking people
we just need grown-ups to be taking
these decisions and I think if they
can't do that and it's clear they can't
they should get out the way and move
over for people who can I mean you're
saying that now so Kirsten said that
earlier What mechanisms are in place for
that to happen at this point because you
know that that's a long shot if it
happened before the end of Parliament
and and I think that's really unfair on
people across the country because it
means this chaos is just carrying on
it's clear that you know conservative
MPS don't want a general election right
now but actually it's not fair people
it's considered tabling a vote
emotionally whether it's what we thought
today was a vote of confidence and we it
wasn't and it was it wasn't who knows
what was going on ultimately
conservative MPS need to recognize that
they are doing the country no favors by
carrying on with this chaos that is
letting the country down it's not fair
on those mortgages it's not fair on on
people who are worrying who worrying
about whether they can put the heat
eating on this winter worrying about
what bit whether they can pay their
bills to have this kind of instability
and Chaos carrying on labor party is
ready we have a team that is ready to
form next government we've got plans
that we've set out but also just ready
to be
seriously you thought that this may have
been a vote of confidence that was that
before after Craig Whitaker who knows
exactly because some of the criticism of
the way they've tabled this motion was
to deliberately Force the hand of the
government and try and set them up put
them into a trap and the trap didn't
close did it because the government won
this very handily due to the labor
motion part of what we were trying to do
is actually prevent fracking happening
and the conservatives said that's what
they would do we've been really clear we
would prevent fracking going ahead we
think it'd be really damaging we think
it's not the right thing in terms of
either Net Zero or in terms of safety or
our energy Supply so we want to stop
fracking so that's why the leg that's
why we put forward even if local
communities say that they want fracking
because that's the way that the
government have kind of have moved this
around haven't they yeah so people have
been really clear that they don't want
fracking and they don't want this and
it's also very bad isn't the idea that
you might get some reduction in your
bill you get cheaper energy who knows
who knows what the conservatives are
planning but it won't solve our energy
security problems it won't cut people's
bills and it won't solve our Net Zero
challenge that we need for the sake of
the planet we're setting out an
alternative about Renewables about tidal
about nuclear and about how to invest in
them through a publicly owned GB energy
that means the taxpayer benefits and we
get cheaper bills as well that's part of
a long-term plan for growth it's part of
a serious labor plan for government and
that's why it's just so shocking and
awful to see this lot just continuing
with the chaos when we could be getting
on with the serious challenges we face
okay thank you but thank you very much
for being with us let's leave it there
thank you so much all right well what
has been another hugely tumultuous day
at Westminster is all from the take
where we have seen the Home Secretary
resign the chief Whip and the shadow
Chief whips say they were quitting but
then being back in post list trust is
still in number 10 and we'll go to
outside number 10x for Sky News at 10
from Downing Street on another day of
turmoil at the top of government
[Music]